in this sprout's teaching technique we
introduce the idea of
student leaders a simple task-based
method teachers can use to build
self-esteem
teach responsibility and help students
take pride in themselves
and their classroom
to create your own student leaders think
about activities that your students can
help you complete
watering plants being in charge of
getting you books or anything that is
easy for them to do
and makes them feel special
next transform these tasks into special
roles for your students
instead of just having your students
water your plants give them the title of
rainmaker instead of getting a book name
them the bookmaster
giving these tasks a title will make
them excited to help you
it will also help them pay attention and
feel good about themselves
some tasks can be daily and some every
few days
it helps to create a student leader
calendar for all your students to see
and make sure that you rotate through
the tasks and that everyone gets a turn
at every task
please use the comments below to let us
know what you think
if you are a student tell us if you've
ever been a student leader
if you are a teacher share your tips on
how to use this in your classroom
we're releasing updates regularly so
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
thank you for watching
you